en
[Musique]
principe il doit laisser à chaque foyer
absolument ball monopinion mon idée là
dessus je suis fair époux et je crois
que la femme doit laisser à son foyer ne
ferait qu il travaille comme moi
pourquoi
s'il ya par exemple ça serait l'homme
qui travaille ça ça la femme qui reste
aussi mon métier me permet de pouvoir
nous besoin je pense que la femme doit
rester au foyer celle de choisir pour
façon on peut pas imposer à quelqu'un de
faire eux
qui sonne n'apporte pas une gêne d'un
employé et si dans les médias ya près
d'un an mais c est ce que votre femme
travaille à l'extérieur oui un travail à
l'extérieur
à la direction des douanes avec moi un
bureau différents travail vous avez des
enfants un petit oui et elle a toujours
travaillé oui elle a toujours travaillé
depuis l'âge de 18 ans pourquoi est-ce
que le travail est bien parce qu'elle
l'heure actuelle et il faut travailler
des oui puisque sa ferme et d'avoir
l'equilibre financiers qui ont faim de
la femme
a part ça la maison elle est coiffeuse
et à la métier qui lui plaît énormément
est-ce que vous pensez que votre couple
pour votre couple ça a été bénéfique
quel travail où ça aurait été mieux car
à chez vous
je pense que si des cas travaillent à
l'extérieur
bien si on avait deux ou trois enfants
peut-être qu'il est avec un seul enfant
je pense que des journées sont longues
balles vous êtes marié monsieur disons
encore oui encore ça veut dire quoi
instance de divorce est ce que votre
femme travaillait à l'extérieur
oui
a commencé à travailler il ya cinq ou
six mois
et on avait acheté une maison et prier
cette raison
variable mais vous avez des enfants j'ai
un enfant et vous pensez que ça a été un
des équipes cause de déséquilibre dans
votre foyer votre femme travaille pas
disons que ça a facilité les choses pour
elle
ils ont qui est une femme beaucoup plus
libre je pense que le travail que
lorsqu'elle rencontre beaucoup de
personnes l'occasion de s'épanouir que
dans ce cas là la maison et ou femme est
beaucoup plus conquête à sortir par
assia la musique et on a plus de sujets
de conversation enfin je pense que c'est
rester à la maison et sera appauvri et à
partir du jour où il y aurait des
enfants quelle sera votre attitude ne
s'est pas ouvert à ce moment là on verra
dit monsieur l'enfant d'accoucher au
mois décembre
et alors elle s'arrêtera certainement
pour le vélo dos vous pensez que c'est
indispensable
bah oui c'est s'il faut payer quelqu'un
pour garder une
voix si vous plaira sa maison parce que
joua les employés ils payent 45 mille
francs une un gosse à garder alors au
mieux car est sa maison avec deux gosses
de toute façon il ya les enfants il va
me rester chez elle et pour le procureur
je suis un congé pas encore aux
convenances personnelles
oui
monsieur est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est mieux votre femme ne travaille pas
d'extérieur actuellement oui quoi parce
que on a des enfants petits et attend
que les enfants sont petits sont petits
ils font mieux que la femme soit à la
maison auprès de ces enfants c'est sûr
si on peut le faire bien sûr en faire et
si votre femme avait manifesté le désir
de continuer à travailler qu est ce que
vous auriez été en main j'aurais pu
aussi bien sûr et libre de travailler
c'est elle veut travailler bien sûr
merci beaucoup je me sens fier
[Musique]